bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue l'émission où l'on discute de
l'actualité en toute liberté surtout
quand on n'est pas d'accord je vous
propose de nous pencher sur les sujets
qui ont retenu notre attention
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est à
l'elysée depuis six mois six mois ces
deux trimestres
c'est plus que la moitié d'une année
scolaire alors on a proposé deux invités
de noter le président de la république
est évidemment dû justifier leurs notes
car il ne peut s'agir d'une note de
gueule cela va de soi nous allons aussi
parler des paradise peppers ce grand
dossier qui sort dans la presse mondiale
sur l'exil fiscal l'optimisation fiscale
la fraude fiscale appelons la comme vous
l'entendez
est-ce que c'est contradictoire au
niveau les français avec les mesures de
baisse des impôts
nous en discuterons nous discuterons
aussi des suites de la tuerie au texas
le président de trump explique
totalement ce n'est pas vraiment une
surprise de revenir sur la libre
circulation des armes aux états unis la
libre possession surtout faut-il revenir
sur ceux sur cette règle non écrite de
la démocratie américaine et puis nous
parlerons de l'islamo gauchisme à la
suite des déclarations de la députée
danielle obono député la france
insoumise qui a expliqué hier que elle
respectait une militante anti racistes
en tout cas qu'elle qualifie comme tel
qui s'attelle à riga bouteldja mais qui
le moins qu'on puisse dire n'est pas
exactement n'importe qui cet islam au
gauchisme c'est un sujet qui revient
régulièrement avec les soupçons de ce
genre de proximité pour la france un sou
mais s'est elle justifiée nous en
parlerons avec en premier lieu le jérôme
jaffré bonsoir merci de nous avoir
rejoints vous êtes un éminent
politologue directeur du cecop le centre
d'études et de connaissances sur
l'opinion publique
vous intervenez régulière -
politiquement show une émission presque
aussi passionnante que point de vue est
votre dernière étude le front national
face à l'obstacle du second tour est
paru à la fondation pour l'innovation
politique cette année en 2017
erwan le nom bonsoir vous êtes
consultant en stratégie maître de
conférences à sciences po
chroniqueur à l'opinion votre dernier
ouvrage la france des opportunités
toutes les bonnes nouvelles qu'on ne
vous dis pas
et a été publié aux éditions des belles
lettres cette année on peut dire que
vous êtes un essayiste libéral pour
résumer les choses frédéric dabi bonsoir
vous êtes politologue et directeur
général adjoint de l'institut ifop
bonsoir alexandre ii avec pio vous êtes
journaliste pages débats les opinions du
figaro êtes en charge du figaro vox
l'espace de débat du figaro.fr mais
aussi du figaro magazine vous êtes
l'auteur des nouveaux enfants du siècle
paru l'année dernière aux éditions du
cerf est ce qu'on peut être vous êtes un
journaliste de sensibilité souverainiste
à vous voir même si je crois que le mot
est usé il faut parler de de france
libre de france indépendante c'est mieux
que de s'entraîner ce les gens savent
pas très bien et vous êtes d'abord un
journaliste parlant du président macron
il est à l'elysée depuis six mois je
vous propose que qu'on s'arrête pour
essayer de donner une note au président
et je ne voudrais pas influencer le jury
mais il ya deux personnes qui se sont
exprimées ce week-end et qui ne trouve
vraiment toutes les qualités de la
planète voire du système solaire à
emmanuel macron il s'agit d'abord de
l'ancien ministre de l'environnement
ségolène royal s'est éteint hier au
grand jury rtl le figaro lci
moi je crois que il faut toujours
regarder les initiatives politiques qui
sont prises et regarder comment ils
peuvent marcher mon souhait le plus
profond c'est que ça marche bien que
l'emploi se développe que la mutation
énergétique se fasse et c'est donc ça ne
me choque pas a priori qu'on puisse
prendre des mesures qui sont
idéologiquement
classé à droite lorsque l'intégration
c'est que c'est également même n'est pas
la seule personnalité du parti
socialiste a apprécié ce côté à la fois
et de gauche et de droite d'emmanuel
macron écouter ce que disait un ancien
directeur général du fmi et espoirs
socialiste à la présidentielle
il s'agit bien sûr de dominique strauss
kahn c'était samedi dernier macro il est
ligoté ni droite
je voudrais qu'il soit et gauche et
droite crois que c'est une bonne chose
que par moment parce que c'est l'intérêt
du pays comme le fait macron les deux
puissent travailler ensemble je crois
que c'est la période des grandes
transformations et que si emmanuel
macron saisit bien sa chance
il peut faire en cinq ans beaucoup de
changements en france qui n'ont pas
existé pendant les trente précédentes
années alors 2011 comme semblent bien
mettre 20 sur 20 au président macron
est-ce aussi votre cas professeur jaffré
écouter ici si je raisonne un électeur
de gauche je donnerais une note sur 10
ont maintenant deux matches on ne met
pas sur 20 maintenant mais sur 10 je
donnerais 4 sur 10 un maquereau et si je
raisonne un électeur de droite je lui
donnerai 8 sur 10 l'électeur de gauche
et ben macro cube bien la fonction
présidentielle mais chercherait en vain
des mesures qui correspondent à ses
idées de gauche lorsqu'il a fait alors
bien sûr il ya la promesse de
suppression de la taxe d'habitation sur
trois ans mais enfin pour le moment il
n'y a rien de concret encore un on est
dans le tangible quand on est un
électeur de gauche et s'est pas encore
là l'électeur de droite lui il a
beaucoup beaucoup de raisons d'être
satisfait des manuels macro parce que
tout simplement il fait ce que sur
l'économique le social et l'éducation
ce que la droite promettait de faire et
quand elle est au pouvoir ne faisait pas
en politique fiscale
il trouve que c'est bien même si en fait
l'électeur de droite dans son grande
majorité n'en profitera pas céder très
riche qui profiteront des mesures macro
mais il trouve quand même que on
prélevait trop sur le capital et ça
nuisait à l'économie donc le lecteur de
droite lui logiquement il a des raisons
d'être satisfait de maquereaux bilan de
l'opération
électoralement c'est pas rentable parce
que macron il a été élu par les voix de
gauche que la droite elle existe
toujours et de plus en plus elle va
exister avec l'élection de la présidence
des républicains qu'elle n'est pas prête
à s'allier avec macron et donc nous
avons des électeurs de gauche qui ne s'y
retrouve pas et des électeurs de droite
qui n'ont pas venir forcément vers macro
donc paradoxalement la faiblesse du
dossier scolaire de macron c'est sa
bonne note auprès des électeurs de
droite presque alexandre avec you will
et moi je suis pas sûr que je raisonne
encore en droite et à gauche parce qu'il
ya que macro est plutôt celui qui a été
élu par les grandes métropoles mais du
mondialisé qui vont bien et qui a un
électorat des classes populaires de la
france périphérique qui a pas forcément
les mêmes la même vision du monde et les
mêmes attentes et à mon avis le le
clivage actuelle se fait sur le rapport
qu'on a à la mondialisation la vision de
ma point elle est très claire il veut
faire une start up nation reliés aux
états unis et à l'europe mais je crois
que c'est un projet de société qui est
vouée à l'échec pour des raisons
historiques mais je crois que même
économiquement ce ne sera pas performant
puisque finalement c'est ce qu'essaie de
faire aussi ses prédécesseurs de manière
moins radicale mais ça n'a pas
fonctionné c'est quand même une
politique qu'on suit maintenant depuis
une trentaine une trentaine d'années
donc je sais sa vision je me reconnais
pas dedans maintenant si on essaie
d'être un peu objectif je dirais que ma
kron avait trois points faibles le
premier c'est est ce qu'il va être
capable d'incarner de d'enfiler les avis
du président disait qu'il était jeune et
c'est là pour le coup il a quasiment 10
/ d'ici là il a
il fait preuve à la vue des solidarités
et d'universitaires inattendue il ya sur
les questions sociétales où il est resté
je crois dans le flou pour l'instant et
ses pas et s'est pas dévoiler et là il
est plutôt à 5 sur 10 ou à cap sur 10 si
on est plus qu elle et puis il ya son
rapport avec ceux qui ne l'ont pas élu
puisse croire que le travail du
président de la république malgré tout
c'est de rassembler au delà de sa base
sociologique or sa base sociologique
elle est extrêmement faible à 24 pour
soi là effectivement je disais tout à
l'heure la france qu'il va bien des
grandes métropoles qui elle est peut
être satisfaite par contre il a toujours
pas réussi à s'adresser au reste des
français que ce soit les classes
moyennes ou les classes populaires même
single
son bilan est assez lourd puisqu'il
apparaît de plus en plus comme le
président des riches donc là ce serait
plutôt 2 sur 2 survie alors ça fait 10
10 + 4 ça fait quatorze plus de ça fait
c'est ce qu'on va diviser par 3 et jeu
trouvera la réponse
ça fait cinq ans que 33 33 ça fait 6
pour jérôme jaffré et et nos internautes
qui se livrent à l'exercice avec nous
andré donne 10 sur 20 donc 5 sur 10 aux
pressions de la république en disant
peut mieux faire vers sa gauche alors
que loïc lui donne zéro tout à l'envers
élèves turbulents qui ne respecte pas
ses camarades moins avantagés en les
traitant de fainéants et et a fait ça ne
manque pas d'esprit
frédéric dans ce n'est pas facile pour
le sondeur de donner une note est de
jouer au beau professeur alors c'est
vrai que les français dans les
différents baromètre de l'ifop qui met
une note moyenne entre 45 et 50 2% ça
dépend de la question qui est posée
insatisfaction dans le jdd ou une cote
d'opinion qui est moins méchante si je
puis dire dans le baromètre ifop
fiducial pour match donc je serai sur ce
5 sur 10 mais ce 5 sur 10 ci se voit
dans le temps et dans l'espace le
l'élève françois hollande six mois après
son élection avait une note très
inférieurs l'élève nicolas sarkozy six
mois après son élection avait une note
supérieure ça tenait très bien à droite
y avait encore une certaine attraction
chez sarkozystes de gauche là emmanuel
macron bénéficient de positions
extrêmement éparpillés et les laits que
son équation
politique directement issue de la
séquence électorale de 2007 tient ce qui
fait qu'il n'ya pas encore de rupture de
dégâts l'opinion un socle extrêmement
fidéliser de sympathisants marche plus
du maître entre neuf et dix sur dix il a
90 95 % de bonnes opinions ça représente
quel pourcentage de l'électorat
française c'est aficionado à paris on a
un socle de sympathisants marque dans
une enquête classique qui est entre 20
et 25% de ce point de vue là le le socle
perdre ses solides les sympathisants
socialistes et non pas de gauche parce
que les socialistes ont encore alors que
ces mecs ils envoyaient plus de signer à
droite qu'à la gauche sow sur une note
de 5 sur 10
et puis comme le disait jérôme jaffré il
ya une vraie attraction d'une partie des
sympathisants républicains sur les
enquêtes il est parfois à 55 60 % de
bonnes opinions parce que il fait une
politique clairement vu comme droite que
lui comme de droite ça son objectif de
transformer le pays ça raconte
complètement has a un écho certain chez
ce peuple de droite qui était tellement
déçu par l'exercice du pouvoir précédent
notamment dessus et nicolas sarkozy et
puis il ya ces deux levier qui lui
permettent d'avoir cette moyenne
la distinction par rapport à son
prédécesseur à ses prédécesseurs
et puis cet objectif de réforme du pays
de transformation du pays maintenant il
ya des signaux faibles
il ya quand même un président
impopulaire qu'au regard des chiffres il
n'est depuis mois d'août 2010 est
impopulaire dans les principaux
baromètre de l'ifop et puis il ya des
mauvaises petite musique la justice -
politique des riches que parce qu'il ya
eu qu un président des riches ça a été
nicolas sarkozy on lui accole - ce terme
que la politique qui mène n'est pas une
politique juste et puis ya clairement
par rapport à ce que disent et georgia
frais sur est très riche
est ce que la politique menée qui me
plaît qui est peut-être qui est en
adéquation avec son programme
présidentiel n'y a pas de rupture
qu'avait connu nicolas sarkozy en fin
d'année 2007
est-ce qu'elle va me bénéficié et de ce
point de vue là il ya des très fortes
interrogations des futurs à notre
moyenne de 5 sur 10 on va demander un
rôle dans sa note mais jérôme jaffré
comment est-ce que vous expliquer
compte tenu de la mauvaise note que vous
imaginez être celle des électeurs de
gauche que ségolène royal ou dominique
strauss kahn donne 10 sur 10 au
président la maîtrise on parle de
ségolène royal les a été nommé me
semble-t-il ambassadeur par emmanuel
macron pour le l'antarctique donc elle
ne va pas injurier quand même la main
qui la nourrit quant à dominique strauss
kahn et bien malgré tout emmanuel macron
fait ce qu'il aurait voulu faire s'il
avait été élu président de la république
et je précise que je pense qu emmanuel
macron n'a pas fait ce qu'a fait
dominique merci beaucoup et revenez dans
votre note
moi je suis pas fan mais notre objectif
qu'on se donne et j'en vois trois et
critères d'évaluation pour emmanuel
macron c1 par rapport à ce que lui-même
se fixer comme objectif sans suite par
rapport à ce qu'il a fait c'est à ses
prédécesseurs et puis de savoir si ça va
lui permettre de passer dans la classe
supérieure d'ailleurs le prochain mandat
1 par rapport à ses prédécesseurs oui je
donne cette fuite comme le com on nous
disait l'électeur de droite qui fait il
a fait des réformes c'est pas incroyable
mais il fait des réformes et en tout cas
il en fait beaucoup plus et dans
l'au-delà meilleur sens que françois
hollande
jusqu'à maintenant il je ne dirais pas
qu'il en fait plus que ce qu'avait fait
la droite dans ses premiers dans ses
premiers mois mais il ya un signe qui
est positif par rapport à ses propres
ambitions de transformation là il n'a
pas la moyenne parce qu'on n'est
clairement pas dans des projets de
transformation de la société ont fait
quelques ajustements du marché du
travail
on touche pas du tout à la dépense
publique on trouve pas du tout à la
sphère publique d'ailleurs de manière
générale il n'y a pas de réformes de
libéralisation de la ville avait promis
de faire cette transformation avec il a
promis il a un discours pendant sa
campagne a eu un discours qui était
relativement ambiguë mais oui j'ai cru
comprendre depuis la rentrée que son
rang les secours étaient la
transformation on n'engage pas des
réformes ont fait la transformation et
on a on porte un projet de
transformation de la société donc vous
dites c'est un transformateur en peau de
lapin s'est passé pas un vrai
réformateur
on ne sait pas c'est un réformiste de
centre gauche comme on peut le trouver
chez les démocrates américains donc il y
a une
vision relativement technocratique de la
société de l'économie qui est dirigé
depuis depuis depuis le sommet de l'état
une vision de la société qui est elle
même divisée en communauté une vision
assez pour le coup très démocrate sens
américain de la société
mais on n'est pas il n'a pas engagé de
transformation dire séparer gagnent
s'est passée la church et on n'aime pas
encore non plus dans les réformes
qu'elle ait pu faire tony blair ou
gerhard schröder il a fait des premières
réformes qui sont importantes pour être
des premiers pas mais on n'est pas
encore dans la transformation de la
société troisième vous êtes déçu
troisième voie la troisième critère 20
déçu non ce que j'ai pas non plus
entretenu d'immenses espoirs mais
troisième critère s qui passe le mandat
suivant et ce qui passe dans la classe
supérieure à ce qu'il est réélu en 2012
je pense qu'il est tôt mais je pense
qu'il ya des signaux faibles et je
rejoins alexandre pour le coup dans ce
que dans ce qu'il disait c'est que c'est
pas tous les jours ouvrables
c'est pas tous les jours mais en en
france entame on a fallu qu un point
d'intérêt que d'intérêts dans mon cas
avoir d'inquiétude dans le sien a
commencé les politiques que fait
emmanuel macron etc ont pu être fait
dans d'autres pays ça a effectivement
pour et fait creuser des inégalités en
tout cas d'avoir pour de transmettre une
impression de décalage entre un une
partie du pays qui va bien une partie du
pays qui va mal ça c'est transcrit mais
je parle sous le contrôle les sondés
sont leurs aux biens aux élections qui
ont suivi aux états unis après barack
obama en république tchèque récemment
alors qu'on aimerait gouvernement qu'à
des bons résultats en allemagne avec un
gouvernement qui a des bons résultats
économiques par 10 par des campagnes
électorales qui ne porte pas sur des
sujets économiques c'est-à-dire qu'on
peut avoir d d d un succès économique
comme je pense que manuel macron peut en
avoir
et pour autant ça ne permet pas aux
candidats sans gaine élections
d'ailleurs on se souvient que c'est
vraiment où le chômage le plus baissé en
france c'était quand lionel jospin était
premier ministre
or il a même pas été qualifié au second
tour de la présidentielle alors je vous
aurais de corée ou sur ce point le
chômage le drame de jospin on sait que
le chômage est remonté dans la dernière
année de son mandat à matignon et que
les français en fait sont plus sensibles
aux dix derniers mois qu'à l'ensemble
des cinq ans donc le pauvre je sais pas
passer son temps à dire il ya eu 920 km
de moins neuf cent mille chômeurs de
moins 5 ans et les françaises dites est
le chômage monte cela dit
yeomans enfin par rapport à ce que vous
venez de dire il me semble important de
ne pas oublier ce qu'un système
politique très particulier en france qui
est un système politique à deux tours de
scrutin dans lequel le problème donc
c'est de se qualifier pour le second
tour d'être assez forts se qualifier
pour le second tour et d'être en
position de battre l'adversaire que vous
trouverez au second tour donc à côté
tout ce que vous dites du jeu très juste
je crois effectivement sur ce que fait
macron sur le plan politique
sur le plan des politiques publiques
vous avez le fait que macron essaye de
construire des oppositions qui soit une
droite très à droite et une gauche très
à gauche qui le place en situation s'il
est assez fort pour se qualifier au
second tour pour pouvoir gagner tandis
que les autres élections dont vous ne
parlez sont des élections à un tour
souvent un système proportionnel et qui
du coup n'ont pas du tout les mêmes
logiques politiques
je voulais faire cette remarque nous
semble et yvon jérôme jaffré est déjà au
taquet pour 2022 les chances de
réélection de daniel wagon juste pour
finir d'une phrase à chacun vous savez à
la fin du bouquin trimestriels y'avait
appréciation du professeur principal sur
les points d'amélioration possibles
alors en une phrase si vous aviez un
conseil au président macron pour qu'ils
s'améliorent
j'ai alors après un peuple il n'y a pas
un rapport satisfaisant au peuple de la
part des manuels macron la façon dont il
parle des français dont il parle aux
français laisse de côté la bo moins la
moitié du pays quand ça ne la blesse pas
et donc là c'est le point le plus
délicat poli chose en parlant de
proximité c'est l'indicateur qui est le
plus bas dans les enquêtes de l'ifop
parce qu'il est proche des
préoccupations s'y connaît le quotidien
des français il est systématiquement
avec une note de 3 5 sur 10 si on
cherche un pourcentage en othe et puis
il a auprès d'un électorat qui est de
deux électorats où il est très faible
france insoumise et front national idée
particulièrement bas avec ce sentiment
d'être méprisés que mépris et mépriser
le présent qui éprouve ses deux
électeurs soyez moins méprisant la
commande
je vais pas m alexandre ce qui a été
fait ou donc élèves un peu trop sûr de
lui sans doute je m'étais dit
s'ajouteraient de l'audace dans la
réforme économique hockey et le dernier
mot revient à l'internaute flou qui nous
dit le jour où il décidera d'alléger les
hauts salaires des députés sénateurs et
ministres il aura peut-être la moyenne
d'une démagogie sans glisser
construisent et moi veut dire les
salaires des députés des sénateurs et
des minus contenu de leurs
responsabilités par rapport à ce que
gagnent des cadres dirigeants
d'entreprises sont des salaires modestes
en réalité compte tenu de leur charge de
travail compte tenu de leurs devoirs de
leurs obligations
nous ne devons pas accepter que des
propos aussi démagogique soient tenues
sont les rectifier au site est en tout
cas sans exprimer son point de vue et
c'est ce que vous vous êtes fait
recharger objet après merci je
compléterai d'une phrase en citant un
sondage ifop le figaro fait au moment
des cités l'ifop à l'usiné au moment où
on cherchait des 100 jours françois
hollande la mesure qui avait le plus
plébiscité c'était sa baisse de 20 ou
30% de son salaire
quel impact cela a eu sur le bilan final
jugé catastrophique par les français je
vous laisse la réponse fin on puisqu'on
parlait des riches continuons mais dans
l'allée méga super riches c'est qu'ils
ont tendance à pratiquer l'évasion
fiscale ce sont ou de très très riches
particuliers ou des grandes entreprises
un consortium de médias notamment nos
confrères du monde réunis dans dans un
dossier qu'on appelle paradise peppers
pardon pour le bon français
ce sont des révélations sur comment
est-ce qu'on peut optimiser fiscalement
et payer moins d'impôts sans forcément
d'ailleurs que ce soit illégale c'est ce
que précise jacques menacé le patron de
la cellule d'investigation de radio
france qui est l'une des parties
prenantes de ce dossier écouter on a mis
au jour un système qui permet à des
grandes entreprises dominique se connaît
bien le problème de transférer de
manière parfaitement légale des chiffres
d'affaires astronomique des sommes
astronomiques des milliards de dollars
des centaines même de milliards de
dollars dans des paradis fiscaux où on
n'existe plus on est invisible
on ne paye pas d'impôts et vous vous
retrouvez avec des sociétés dans les
pays où elles produisent leurs richesses
ou finalement une elle passe sous les
radars fiscaux et où par ailleurs les
états et on le verra là dans les jours
qui viennent
donne du cic et du crédit d'impôt
compétitive compétitivité en plus ça
c'est un point important il ya des
choses dans ce que dit jacques monin on
va commencer par le deuxième point c'est
d'un côté on baisse les charges c'était
le cic eux sous françois hollande ça
continue avec emmanuel macron on baisse
les sf et en même temps on apprend que
les super riches les multinationales et
c'est de payer encore moins d'impôts sk
pas là une contradiction et escales et
politiquement intenable a emmené en moi
je veux absolument voir contradiction
c'est à dire que si on baisse les impôts
et si les gens font de non pas de
l'évasion parce que à ce que j'ai lu
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas prouvé
qu'ils aient de fraude fiscale ont
parfaitement d'optimisation allanche la
nuancer et que dans un cas c'est légal
dans l'autre pas elle est quand même
importante donc dans les deux cas on ad
on a des entreprises qui cherchent à
habas comment à subir une pression
fiscale moins forte soit en utilisant
l'ensemble des capacités que le droit à
leur offre
alors après le monde le new york times
le guardian radio france qui sont un
ensemble les 10 de médias qui sont aussi
politiquement orientés qui on estime que
c'est immoral et que s'ils paient pas
assez d'impôts
et bien c'est une question de régulation
de fiscalité mais après ça n'a
absolument rien d'illégal ensuite effet
ces entreprises aujourd'hui bénéficient
des aides et
et optimisent leur fiscalité parce que
on a en france une fiscalité qui est
parmi l'une des plus élevées au monde
qui ne parmi les plus élevés en de
l'oscd eux parmi les plus élevés de tous
et c'est normal c'est normal les gens
qu'ils ont cités sont pas tous français
loin de là et d'autres lois ce qui lui
paraît normal que la société ducasse 47
3% 10 aces lé public et les pme 30 % oui
est ce que c'est normal parce que
certains bons avocats
est ce que c'est normal que les
entreprises cherchent à payer le moins
d'impôts comme beaucoup d'entre nous
cherchons à payer le moins d'impôts dès
qu'on a l'opportunité
oui je suis désolé il ya un discours qui
ne va absolument qui me choque dans
l'édito du monde d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'idée sous jacente que ces entreprises
vol l'état que les gens qui optimise
fiscalement vol l'état elle ne vole
personne l'argent n'appartient pas à
l'état dans ce pays
l'argent appartient aux entreprises
elles ont une manière écoliers et aux
particuliers bien aux gens qu'il est aux
gens qui les produisent il n'y a aucune
raison que l'argent reviennent de droit
à l'état et donc on a un édito dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui qui dit que c'est
une porte atteinte à la démo que les
entreprises portent atteinte à la
démocratie
je sais je trouve ça profondément
choquant elle porte atteinte peut-être
au système de redistribution actuelle
tel qu'il fonctionne en france mais pas
la démocratie ce qui porte atteinte à la
démocratie c'est le discours selon
lequel l'état doit tout contrôler et
contrôler toute la richesse qui est
produite dans ce pays et maintenant nous
sommes peut-être assister à un moment de
télévision intéressant ou alexander kyo
défend le journal le monde
avec 117 à vous mais je ne sais pas si
je défends le journal le monde mais en
tout cas si on veut que les classes
moyennes les petits entrepreneurs soit
un peu moins taxés il faudra peut-être
que l'international le soit un peu plus
ma chute pas d'accord ça pose
effectivement un problème de démocratie
knight hubert et apple ne paient
quasiment pas d'impôt étant donnée leur
puissance ça ça fait des multinationales
sa relation avec ça vous trouvé ça très
bon temps je trouve je ne trouve pas
normal que des entreprises ne soient pas
taxés de la même façon pour les mêmes
activités
je corrige ce que j'ai dit que quand
j'ai parlé trop rapidement tout à
l'heure il faut pas normal qu'une
entreprise qui fasse la même activité
soit pas taxé de la même façon mais je
ne vois pas pourquoi l'état aurait
vocation à taxer systématiquement toutes
les
si vite économique alexandre mais moi je
pense qu'il est quand même préférable de
taxer ces multinationales qui ont quand
même je crois les moyens c'est pas c'est
pas des pauvres plutôt que de renier sur
le fonctionnement des hôpitaux plutôt
que de taxer les retraités donc là il
lui a laissé c'est ce que ce que macron
dans le budget de la sécu a parlé de
faire des économies sur le
fonctionnement des zones rio je sais pas
où est ce qu'ils voient ce qu il va le
trouver pour les retraités ils ont
augment il augmente donc ne me dites pas
ça donc je pense que il ya aujourd'hui
des petits entrepreneurs qui ont qui ont
du mal qui on a l'impression d'être à
surcharger et d'avoir d'énormes unsa un
certain nombre de réglementations et les
règles sont pas les mêmes sont pas les
mêmes pour tout le monde je trouve ça
scandaleux on a aujourd'hui une
oligarchie qui se servent finalement de
la mondialisation pourra échapper à la
solidarité nationale c'est tout j'ai
besoin de dire que les français sont
plutôt du côté du point de vue
d'alexandre ils sont au juste
c'est le public en france c'est je crois
un peu pas 80 milliards d'euros
l'évasion fiscale parlons même pas de
l'optimisation seo 6,81 milliards
d'euros peut-être que si on récupère est
là pour le coup qu'on appliquait la loi
et qu'on va récupérer cet argent là où
on ferait moins d'économies sur des
choses qui sont fondamentales pour la
cohésion nationale frédéric ans je
disais que le regard des français est
plutôt proche des propos d'alexandre
dans le sens où depuis une quinzaine
d'années le regard sur les entreprises a
quand même beaucoup changé il y avait
avant des jugements c'est catégorique et
globaux et au fur et à mesure parce qu'à
une meilleure culture économique de la
part des français
il ya une sorte de distinction entre la
tpe de proximité c'est le commerce près
de chez soi
la pme vertueuse qui se bat là dans la
compétition intéressant et puis les
grands groupes qui reste au lit qui
reste complètement repoussé et
repoussoir est ce qu on lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on apprend que hubert
nice ne paye pas beaucoup d'impôts ce
sont des choses qui dans un pays on a la
passion de l'égalité et la passion de la
dénonciation des inégalités passe
extrêmement mal donc je pense que de ce
point de vue là ce type de révélations
ne peut que kaka s'est fortement des
français dans un contexte où pour
revenir à ce qu'on s'est dit sur
emmanuel macron il ya dès qu'il ya un
vrai malaise qui monte dans nos enquêtes
qualitatives auprès des français qui se
définissent comme appartenant aux
classes moyennes alors on est toujours
plus casse moyenne que l'on est
réellement qui est que nous sommes
elles disent nous sommes trop riche pour
bénéficier d'une exemption exemption de
l'impôt sur le revenu l'assiette a quand
même c'est quand même très fortement
réduit depuis une quinzaine d'années je
crois de 10 points
manuel valls à supprimer la première
tranche d'impôt sur le revenu et elles
disent aussi nous sommes pas assez
riches pour faire de l'optimisation
fiscale et tout repose sur nous ce type
de nouvelles ne peut qu'exacerber leur
frustration et leur mécontentement
jaffray oui le risque de ces parutions
c'est que les français ne retiennent pas
du tout cette distinction subtile entre
l'optimisation fiscale et l'évasion
fiscale et qui considère donc que tout
ça c'est des voleurs pour résumer assez
simplement les choses
à partir de là nous avons une situation
très inquiétante parce que l'on jette en
pâture y compris le nom de la reine
elizabeth d'angleterre fusée du peu pour
les citoyens britanniques est évident
que c'est pas elle qui gère elle-même
son portefeuille d'affaires on peut
penser que la pauvre elle est au dessus
de ces contingences et toute l'équipe
trump évidemment qui lui ne veut être
entouré que des riches quand vous êtes à
nouveau reine c'est normal oui bien sûr
dans le débat n'est pas loin des marques
très mme clinton clinton hillary lui
reprocher à trump de ne pas payer
d'impôt fédéral depuis 20 ans et trois
superbes a répondu c'est la preuve que
je suis très intelligent est évident que
beaucoup d'américains sont admiratifs de
cette situation mais en france compte
tenu nous de notre culture très
égalitaire effectivement il ya un risque
si vous voulez de coupure accrue entre
les élites et le peuple sentiment que
les ai dit
respectent pas la loi qu'ils fabriquent
eux mêmes c'est ça qui est insupportable
aux français comme idée et c'est ça que
des affaires comme celle-ci où on
confond l'optimisation l'évasion et ça
c'est intolérable
optimisation évasion fronte ce ne sont
pas les mêmes choses ce ne sont pas les
mêmes termes
or ça nous est présentée comme étant la
même chose faut vraiment rentré dans les
papiers du journal le monde dans le
détail des papiers gras le monde pour
qu'on finisse par dire ah ben non c'est
pas de l'évasion fiscale c'est de
l'optimisation et l'optimisation c'est
le b à ba de tout industriel de tout
chef d'entreprise vont tout extrême non
parce que c'est un monde et l'ont imposé
grands avocats et pas le patron de la
pme qui est lui paie 30 % d'impôt sur
les sociétés et et qui sait vivre le
pays avec mais crée de l'emploi
du coup je ferai c'est en fait le risque
c'est que la mondialisation soit perçue
par les français comme ceux qui fait
fermer les usines en france pour les
pauvres et ce qui permet de payer moins
d'impôts pour les riches
en tout cas c'est les présentations
extrême que l'on peut faire et on voit
bien la difficulté du combat qui est
amenée pour emmanuel macron par exemple
puisqu'il et défend la mondialisation
défendre ce genre mais il est évident
que les grandes multinationales nouvelle
les google apple amazon et compagnie
les français demandent qu'ils payent
leurs impôts en france sur leur activité
qu'il mène en france et qu'il puisse
jouer un des problèmes que nous avons
dans la construction européenne pour le
coup évident et là je suis obligé de
rendre les armes sur ce point c'est la
concurrence fiscale entre les pays
européens qui fait qu'effectivement vous
jonglez et vous place l'essentiel de vos
activités en irlande pour payer
pratiquement pas de réponse et le grand
choeur et elle était quand même dire les
gens pendant de longues années du
luxembourg avec la commissaire à la
concurrence gérer une société dans les
bahamas parenthèse pour voilà je pense
que l'europe plutôt paie des
fonctionnaires à produire d'énormes
inutile effectivement devrait se battre
sur cette question de la fiscalité mais
maintenant on peut difficilement accuser
mais malgré ce geste ailleurs dans le
commissariat de la commission européenne
d'être une amie et dégâts des grands
opérateurs numériques mais juste de
remarquer cette amende est sûr sûr sûr
le patron pme qui subit de la fiscalité
énorme c'est vrai mais vais évidemment
c'est vrai évidemment c'est plus
difficile pour lui que pour la grande
reprise mais la solution c'est pas de
dire que puisqu'il a un niveau de charge
décharge au sens
physique dû dire énorme on doit monter
le niveau de charge pour tout le monde
il vaut peut-être la bc pour les pme via
la solution d'égalité doit pas être
l'égalité par le pire
ensuite sur le sur le sur une remarque
par contre sur les conséquences
politiques je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit hier que ya le
raisonnement à dire peu économique que
je tiendrais puis le les conséquences
politiques que çà et là où je pense que
jérôme jaffré c'est que par ses
comportements c'est les angles par leur
comportement ces entreprises ainsi qu'un
certain nombre de grands dirigeants
donnent le sentiment de se mettre en
dehors de la communauté nationale en de
ne pas vouloir respecter les règles
fiscales politiques et autres et est-ce
que c'est très mal vécu par l'opinion
publique comme jeu et je crois que c'est
d'une certaine façon la même dynamique
dans les questions d'immigration qu'on a
un c'est que les français ont le
sentiment qu'un certain nombre de
personnes se met en dehors de la commune
delà du cadre de la politique nationale
du cat de la société française et que
ces comportements de d'auto exclusion de
la société sont très mal sont très peu
apprécié mais et troisième remarque sur
le patient pour l'égalité 1-1 économique
s'appelle alberto alesina kiptoo centre
gauche italien qui vit aux etats-unis a
publié alors qu'il ya une dizaine
d'années maintenant une étude va
expliquer pourquoi
comment les français les aime comment
les européens et les américains vivent
la fiscalité
il disait en europe les français
notamment et les européens de manière
générale sont convaincus qu'ils n'ont
aucune chance de réussir par eux mêmes
parce que le marché est biaisé parce que
l'éducation est biaisé et parce que il
ya du chômage donc enfin alors que les
américains pensent que même si c'est
faux ans dans les statistiques que ils
peuvent devenir riche
est ce que il avec un de ses collègues
qui l'ont mené l'étude sur tous les pays
européens les états unis et la
conclusion était que c'est justement
parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils n'ont pas de
chance que les européens privilégient
les privilégie par dont la fiscalité
alors que les américains peuvent les
jeunes fiscale team face le privé
notamment parce qu'on a encore le sujet
il faut être aussi efficace
pourquoi taxer les retraités est ce
qu'il est logique que les retraités qui
touchent 1200 euros par mois parce que
c'est pas les retraités super riches
mais le second par mois soit ils sont
capables d'échapper à la taxation que
leurs autres thoniers sont pas capables
et puis après il ya des choses qui sont
proportionnelles et il ya aussi
l'intérêt collectif peut-être qu'il faut
taxer moins ce qu'ils proviennent de
l'enfant en fonction qui conçoit réalise
fiscale du portugal france
comment la preuve que la preuve que les
français fuient la fiscalité française
le portugal un régime mais là la fir
quasi pc classe bayel vous plaire titre
qui paye à la place de grandes
multinationales qui rapporte assez peu à
l'économie française dont il ya une
logique d'efficacité aussi dans
l'économie joue alors on est totalement
libéré on taxe personne pourquoi mais il
faut tout mettre sur la table etc sans
devait que je propose d'aborder un autre
sujet malheureusement autrement plus
tragique hier a eu lieu dans une église
baptiste du texas une tuerie effroyable
faisant 26 morts
une fois de plus le débat sur la liberté
d'utilisation des armes aux états unis
est revenu sur le devant de l'actualité
donald trump sans surprise a déclaré ce
matin que ça n'était pas du tout parce
qu'il y avait trop d'armes aux états
unis qu'une telle tuerie avait eu lieu
écouter le président américain parce que
selon une information qui vient de nous
arriver
les motivations du tueur serait
familiale ne s'agirait donc pas de dunes
d'une affaire de terrorisme
en tout cas très tight dhabi comment est
ce qu'on explique que les américains
finalement c'est toujours une majorité à
être pour la libre circulation et la
libre l'attention des armes malgré
toutes ces affaires je suis quand même
tombé sur un sondage fait par ce guide
presse au lendemain de la tuerie de
las vegas ou des choses quand même bouge
un petit peu compte tenu d'une part de
la litanie des fusillades compte tenu du
fait que ça semble un problème sans fin
je rappellerai que bowling for columbine
de michael moore sa date de 2002 avant
que les larmes récente de barack obama
il ya un immense sentiment d'impuissance
il ya des américains qui sont de plus en
plus favorables à des contrôles accrus
et sur cette question il ya un clivage
extrêmement fort entre sympathisants je
sais pas si ce terme se dire états unis
mais entre proches des républicains et
électeurs démocrates les républicains
sont clairement sur la position de
donald trump qui avait dit entre
parenthèses que la tuerie du bataclown
n'aurait pas pu arriver aux états unis
car tout le monde est armé
on a une opinion qui bouge un peu mais
la question qui n'est jamais posée dans
toujours savions pas soit il supprimer
le deuxième amendement tout est la base
de toutes ces affaires c'est bon bien
sûr fait l'existence de cette cette
rifle de cette nra qui est extrêmement
puissante qu avec la national rifle
association facile par château et ses
deuxièmes bien un jules l'angliciste
géraud que j'appris m'a bien corrigé
merci
mais surtout c'est le fait que ce
deuxième peu amendements tiens et n'est
pas encore entré comme un commun comme
un comme un sujet de débat aux états
unis est ce que c'est parce que jérôme
jaffré le le symbole de larmes comme
étant le l'instrument par excellence de
l'autonomie est plus fort que toutes les
affaires et notamment chez les électeurs
de droite
manifestement si vous voulez vous avez
un sentiment de liberté individuelle de
droits individuels extrêmement fort dans
la culture américaine qui fait que vous
êtes responsable vous même il ya d'alors
pour site pour citer les enquêtes il ya
un américain sur trois qui possède une
arme à feu chez lui un américain sur
trois et encore quand je dis une arme à
feu ça n'est pas tout à fait vrai la
plupart au plus que par ma collection
chez eux et en ont toutes une série donc
nous avons une situation où il ya un
blocage
j'ajoute que
les lobbys agisse des lobby des armes
sont extrêmement puissants finances très
fortement le parti républicain les
candidats républicains au moment des
élections et donc vous arrivez un
blocage c'est-à-dire qu'on a cette
situation au trump c'est l'américain
moyen devenu président qui explique
vertigineusement que c'est pas du tout
un problème dame celle un problème de
santé mentale de la part du tireur ne
lui vient pas à l'esprit l'idée que si
le tireur avait un problème de santé
mentale s'il n'avait pas d'armes
il y aurait peut-être eu moins de dégâts
quant aux motivations vous avez qualifié
de familial
il me semble que les tué 26 personnes
dans une église baptiste ne relève pas
de motivation familiale il faudra
creuser un peu plus la chose parce que
tous nos auditeurs tourner aux
téléspectateurs qui ont des motivations
familiale dans leur vie dont peut-être
un peu surpris de la formule j'ajoute
j'ajoute que selon l'afp il s'agirait
d'un différend avec sa belle famille sa
belle mère mais effectivement on peut ne
pas aimer sa belle mère heureusement pas
toujours à ce type d'extrémité valentin
pilar du figaro.fr nous a rejoints
qu'est-ce conditions les réseaux sociaux
de cette affaire charles valentin alors
il y à une question très française qui
plane sur les réseaux et vous me voyez
venir je pense et pourquoi ne pas
interdire les armes
voilà tout simplement ça paraît évident
on commence avec juba case sur le site
internet du figaro
rien de neuf ils veulent des armes en
vente libre et ils les ont
inévitablement des barges et autres
terroristes en ont aussi on bascule sur
facebook où les commentaires tombées en
cascade
hier soir sur nos articles avec toujours
le même ton vous en parlais tout à
l'heure
zhu nous dit tant que le deuxième
amendement est intouchable nous ne
seront guère étonné car c'est un droit
constitutionnel de porter une arme pour
sa protection
aux états unis on à mamadou qui
surenchérit il est temps que le
gouvernement américain révise le
problème des armes à feu
au final cette approche dominent les
réseaux francophone avec ces 3 réactions
qui se sont enchaînés hier soir sur
facebook
jean nous dit les etats-unis et leurs
éternels problèmes de libre circulation
des armes ou encore valérie arrêter de
vendre des armes dit elle
loulou seul le lobby des armes la nra
vous on en reparle est également tout à
l'heure n'arrêtera pas de vendre des
armes
on a aussi donc du coup patricia donc
voilà qui s'attriste de cette situation
et qui nous dit qu'au final elle finira
par ne plus être choqués et c'est une
réaction qui a vraiment revenait
fréquemment sur les réseaux les gens
considèrent qu'on s'habitue
on s'y habitue voilà exactement mais du
coup une interrogation se pose c'est
celle de 1996 en australie avez vous
entendu ça vous rappelle quelque chose
cette fusillade de masse en 96 en
australie je vous fais un petit rappel
des faits en australien qui abat 35
personnes et en blessant 23 autres dans
une petite ville à l'est de l'australie
ce la plus importante tuerie de masse de
l'histoire du pays et douze jours plus
tard le premier ministre de l'époque
promulgue une nouvelle loi
six cent cinquante mille armes sont
rachetés par la police à leur
propriétaire en un an et après ça la
vente d'armes automatiques et semi
automatique devient interdite sans
aucune raison valable il sera possible
d'en acheter
voilà donc au final alexandre ii vecchio
messieurs pourquoi ne pas prendre
exemple sur le cas australien oui moi je
suis assez d'accord c'est quand même je
pense là la seule démocratie qui compte
11000 ment pas rond parma feu donc prêt
je pense que c'est compliqué pour donald
trump parce qu'il a été soutenu par un
lobby c'est celui des armes à feu et
quand bien même ils voudraient changer
de pied ce qui est possible avec un
personnage aussi imprévisible il ya
quand même le concret le congrès dans la
système démocratique américain
extrêmement compliqué donc c'est un
programme un problème qui parait
insoluble mais il paraît effectivement
absurde que la plus grande démocratie du
monde et ce problème mais si renan le
problème c'était pas dans les armes que
la violence et la société américaine il
ya une comparaison qui est parfois les
failles canada entre les états unis
n'ont avec la suisse parce que vous
savez qu'en suisse comme un système de
réserve militaire
presque dans chaque famille suisse il ya
un fusil d'assaut qui est caché sous le
lit pour que les suisses puissent armée
en cas d'agression or il n'ya jamais ce
genre d'affaires peut-être parce que la
société suisse et plus paisible cité
américaine et donc suscite moins de
moins 2 des règlements
je connais alors je connais moins la
société suisse mais c'est aussi une
question de taille
il ya probablement plus de deux cas de
meurtres aux états unis par la taille à
l'adulation que qu'en suisse sa merci
mais c'est vrai il est probablement vrai
que la cité américaine et plus accoutumé
à la violence que ne peut l'être la
suisse mais prenons un autre exemple
s'était israéliennes sont associés d'une
société où les gens font observer six
militaires sont également se protéger
son réserviste et qui est donc et qui
est aussi plus accoutumé à une forme de
violence que ne peut l'être la suisse
pour le coup puisque ils sont victimes
d'attentats réguliers mais ça ne fait
pas d'eux une société violente comme
come on come on le ressent aux états
unis je voudrais juste revenir sur sur
un point ce moment là ce qui s'est dit
ravi il suffit de le supprimer en
conclusion que ce soit de faire une
excuse fille de faire une d'adopter un
texte comme on l'a vu le veulent a fait
l'australie il ya comme l'a dit
alexandre une question qui va bien au
delà que du simple elle à sa plainte
d'option d'un texte la question du
fédéralisme américain en fait ce que
l'idée c'est que pour supprimer le
second amendement en tout cas le changer
il faut l'accord des états c'est à dire
qu'il faut que le gouvernement fédéral
pousse les états dans une dans une
démarche de
le travail commun et pour les etats unis
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
spontanée c est au contraire plutôt
généralement vécu comme comme une
atteinte à la liberté des états et donc
à celle à laquelle derrière la question
de la réglementation des armes à des
questions et beaucoup plus philosophique
presque de tout cas de philosophie
politique qui se posent ils ont fait ça
quand même la peine de mort est
cependant il ya une petite dizaine
d'années jusqu'en 76 où il ya eu une
abolition plutôt un moratoire sur la
peine de mort aux états unis
merci beaucoup frédéric nous reste merci
aussi à vraiment un pilote il nous reste
quelques minutes pour traiter un dernier
sujet ce qu'on appelle peut-être par
facilité l'islamo gauchisme c'est à dire
une proximité réelle ou supposée entre
d'un côté une partie de la gauche
radicale fortes comme la france
insoumise et des mouvements
communautaristes souvent défenseurs
inconditionnels de l'islam une pièce à
verser au dossier
une députée la france insoumise danièle
obono qui s'exprimait hier sur radio j
et qui parlait de houria bouteldja c'est
une militante porte-parole de d'un
mouvement des indigènes de la république
je vous propose de l'écouter tout de
suite
est ce que vous confirmez que vous
respectez le parcours et la femme mme
houria bouteldja vous le respecter et je
respecte la militante anti raciste parce
qu'eric et avec qui on vous considérez
que c'est une militante anti raciste bah
oui moi c'est c'est dans le mouvement
antiraciste que je les connais sur les
choses elle dit 1 c'était le 3 mars 2015
à oslo les juifs sont les boucliers les
tirailleurs de la politique impérialiste
française et de sa politique islamophobe
si antiraciste aussi racistes ces
déclarations ben je sais pas ben je suis
pas d'accord avec ce qu'a dit la après
encore une fois je vous dis le fait est
que elle fait partie du mouvement
antiraciste alors pour être tout à fait
précis la même danièle obono a publié
une mise au point sur son compte
facebook en disant je ne suis pas et je
n'ai jamais été membre du pays air le
parti des indigènes de la république
je suis en profond désaccord avec leur
thèse frédéric dabi à votre avis c'est
quoi c'est assez des malentendus ces
histoires où est ce qu'il ya une forme
d'alliance objective
peut-être avec des intérêts électoraux
commun
alliance objective je n'ai absolument
aucune idée c'est vrai que ça avait
quand même à plusieurs reprises que
cette députée danielle obono tient des
propos qui semblent je tirais sur
d'autres sujets nuance et enfin
relativiser la menace de l'islam au duo
dix hommes politiques de distinguo
fascisme 20 de lys la nuit cela elle
elle semble dédouaner mais elle est
gênée lorsqu'on entend d'entretien fait
avec frédéric haziza 7 houria bouteldja
que les proches de la france insoumise
avait plusieurs fois taclé lors de
débats télévisés sur ses propos sur
l'homosexualité sur israël enfin voila
je pense que l'impact sur l'opinion
publique ne peut être qu'extrêmement
marginal danièle obono est peu connu des
français elle a été élue il ya très très
peu de temps mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être une épine dans le pied de jean
luc mélenchon qui connaît d'après ce
qu'il a dit lui-même une sorte de petite
déprime après six mois d manueel macron
il faut pas l'oublier parce que si c'est
quand même eu un vrai décalage entre une
des sources du front de gauche et
l'histoire personnelle jean luc
mélenchon c'est à dire l'attachement au
combat antiraciste à la laïcité
manuel valls hier lors d'un lors d'une
émission radiodiffusée avait parlé d'une
tribune qu'il avait signé avec vincent
peillon et jean luc mélenchon en 2003
sur la sur la laïcité sur
l'antisémitisme dans les banlieues là on
voit très bien que du côté de la france
a soumise ces tirs un peu à huê est à
dire je fais pour y avoir deux
explications à ces rapprochements même
s'ils sont pas institutionnels à êtres
idéologique c'est à dire que de voir
dans le musulman le nouveau prolétaires
donc la nouvelle figure de l'exploiter
ce qui pour un parti très à gauche peut
être un vrai combat
et puis aussi électoralement on voit que
la france insoumise et très forte par
exemple en seine saint denis où ils ont
souffert de ma part quatre députés et
donc un intérêt électoral de d'avoir
avec soi des populations d'origine
immigrée
oui je ne retiens quand même ni l'une ni
l'autre de ces interprétations mais je
relève et dans votre sens que d'après
les enquêtes qui ont été faites
le jour du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous avez la majorité
absolue plus de 50 % des musulmans qui
dès le premier tour on vote et jean luc
mélenchon
voilà ça c'est un élément qu'il ne faut
quand même pas oublier dans cette
affaire et qui fait du coup un problème
extrêmement grave pour jean luc
mélenchon lui même parce que précisément
il ne peut pas prêter le flanc à de tels
le propos à de telles accusations
la conception de mélenchon si vous
voulez c'est mon mouvement est
totalement libre je suis bien sûr le
lider maximo celui qui définit la ligne
et qui dit ce qu'il convient de penser
et personnellement je suis anti raciste
et un vrai laïc mais parmi les membres
de mon mouvement et disent ce qu'ils
veulent ils font ce qu'ils veulent c'est
un mouvement libre dans une interview
récente au 1
l'hebdomadaire un indi spx est un
mouvement c'est un collectif et c'est
pas pour chacun dit ce qu'il veut sans
mouvement gazeux il dit même ce qui est
assez douteux comme propos mais voilà
est ce que dit danièle obono à plusieurs
reprises est inacceptable en vérité et
jean luc mélenchon ne doit pas
l'accepter parce que sinon le ver est
dans le fruit
c'est à dire certes danièle obono n'est
pas connue aujourd'hui
mais ces propos seront de plus en plus
connus et ils auront de plus en plus
d'importance donc je pense que mélenchon
un vrai problème c'est de mettre le holà
d'autant plus nettement qu'il
précisément il bénéficie du vote
musulman et qui ne doit pas répondre
entre l'islamo gauchisme et l'islam au
fascisme
et pour lui la différence doit être
marquée très nettement
c'est capital me semble-t-il un accent
il va peut-être changer de pied surtout
que c'est pas sa tradition politique
c'est plutôt is qualifie lui-même de
robespierristes donc on le voit
difficilement faire alliance avec
l'islam si ce n'est qu' il a quand même
parfois semblé tenter de surfer la thur
notamment ses propos sur manuel valls où
il dit qu'il est proche de l'extrême
droite israélienne on peut penser qu'ils
flattent un électorat des banlieues dont
l'antisioniste ans à se confondre
parfois avec l'antisémitisme donc c'est
une pente très très dangereuse j'en
reviens à à daniel o
au beau noël et à mon avis c'est un
automatique de dérive profond de la
première celle de l'enterrer de
l'antiracisme qui à force d'exalter
finalement les identités se retrouve
avec une société fractionné de la guerre
contre tous contre tous donc c'est un
des paradoxes de l'antiracisme c'est de
prétendre combattre le racisme et
d'instaurer quasiment la notion de race
qui existaient pas forcément dans un
état républicain et l'autre dérive c'est
celle d'une partie de la gauche de la
gauche radicale il a quand même à mon
avis une nébuleuse rouge bien vos rouge
verte qui est va effectivement de bono
en passant ya pas que des hommes
politiques en passant par plenel ravva
d'or etc qui voit dans l'utopie isla
nice la continuation de l'utopie
révolutionnaire communiste et qui voit
la poursuite de la lutte des classes
comme une lutte pour reprendre leur
propre terminologie entre les dominés et
les 2000 ont donc une sorte de lutte des
races et ça c'est une évolution très
préoccupante de la gauche qui verse dans
un multiculturalisme qui est totalement
contraire à l'universalisme républicain
toute petite partie de la cour de la
bouffe qui effectivement dans cet essai
idéologique mais il ya une partie plus
large de la gauche
et d'ailleurs ça va être intéressant de
voir comment macron se positionne
là-dessus qui par clientélisme qui dans
certaines villes certaines communes de
banlieue a fait des accommodements
raisonnables avec avec des gens peu
fréquentables d'ailleurs ça va jusqu'à
la droite jusqu'à la branche juppé
ouvert de droits ça va jusqu'à la droite
jeux psp d'accord alors maintenant vous
avez 20 secondes 20 secondes à rodez
pour dire je suis assez d'accord avec
alexandre vient de dire avec une nuance
près
c'est au tour une précision presse et
que c'est un héritage de culturel du
communisme et que les communistes
aujourd'hui sont pas du tout sur la
ligne de jean luc mélenchon il ya une
vraie différence entre sur ces questions
là entre le front de gauche et le parti
communiste qui est très clair mais il ya
cet anti raciste et qui transforme la
cité française en vision en société
complètement racialisées et même si ça
reste marginal c'est extrêmement
dangereuse que ces propos dans les
banlieues dans les volets ou
l'antisémitisme est plus fort que nos
réseaux la salle et françaises ces
ravageurs essais et c'est un vrai péril
pour la blonde pour la santé
démocratique en france
merci beaucoup
et je laisse à votre réflexion cette
dernière interpellation d'un internaute
bernat allusion à danièle obono il n'en
a pas marre le camarade mélenchon de cet
entourage irresponsable et bien voilà
c'est tout pour ce soir merci d'avoir
été fidèles à point de vue on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
[Musique]